وداعا للخصوصيه تخيل ان الافكار التي تدور
في راسك لم تعد سريه بعد اليوم فقد بات من
السهل قراءتها بالطبع ليس عن طريق زرع
شرائح بالدماغ كما يشاع دائما بل عبر
تقنيات الذكاء الاصطناعي التي اثبتت انها
قادره على قراءه ما يدور في العقول وهذا
ما فعله علماء بجامعه الامريكيه عدم طوروا
تقنيه يمكنها ترجمه الافكار من خلال تحليل
صور الرنين المغناطيسي لتدفق الدم الى
مناطق مختلفه في المخ وبالتالي مراقبه
النشاط العصبي بطريقه غير جراحيه ببساطه
اكثر تسمح هذه التقنيه للعلماء بالنظر الى
انماط النشاط العصبي وتطابقها مع سلاسل من
الكلمات ذات معنى ورغم هذا التطور الفريد
برزت مخاوف تتحدث عن خطوره هذه التقنيه
بالتنصت او التجسس على شخص ما سرا دون
علمه مستقبلا